have you ever found yourself thinking
i want a way to easily view a sequence
position in my gene
for example maybe you work with the
human tp53 gene
and you want to see coding position 586
in one of the transcripts i'll show you
two ways to do this in our genome data
viewer
the first uses the exon navigator widget
which sits directly above the graphical
sequence viewer
i'm displaying chromosome 17 and i've
already searched for the tp53 gene
as you can see this gene has several
transcripts
you can use the transcript menu within
the exon navigator
to select a particular transcript i'm
selecting
nm000546.version6.
note that you'll only be able to choose
transcripts from the latest ncbi gene
annotation release
these circles in the navigator represent
each exon in the selected transcript
a mouse over on the exon circle provides
information about the exon
including the exon number and the cds
range
on the genomic record the tp53 gene
happens to be annotated on the minus
strand of the genomic record
which is why the exon numbers decrease
as you move from left to right
but you can always flip the strands if
you prefer using the tools menu
we're looking for coding position 586 in
this transcript
so let's make a guess and start with
exon 6.
i'll click on that circle in the exon
navigator and it zooms directly to that
complete exon
i'll hover my mouse in the purple
transcript we are interested in
and a tooltip pops up showing the exon
number
and positional i set my mouse over this
g
at mrna position 737 and cds position
so pretty close to 586 a quick tip
if you click on the transcript in the
viewer a ruler displays
the mrna coordinates making it easier to
mouse over the position you want
here is the position we're looking for
cds
a right click with the mouse lets you
set a marker at that position
i won't do that but i will zoom in a bit
to point out that you can easily see the
amino acids in this region
and that a mouse over on the red protein
object
shows that our cds position 586
is this arginine at protein position 196
let's now look at the second way to find
a position which is to use
the tools go to menu in the viewer
i'll open that menu and paste in an hgvs
like expression
for our coding position in the
transcript i've pasted in the
ncbi accession dot version number
followed by a colon
then lowercase c dot 586
and of course the bare genomic location
would also work
7674945
finally the last tip you can download
all of the exons for a given transcript
from a link in the download fasta
section of the tooltip for the
transcript
to get the sequence for individual exons
use the exon navigator
right click on a circle and you can copy
paste the sequence
we would love to have your feedback and
questions so please use the feedback
link
in the help menu